Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Surely this will be the last opportunity for me to address you. I address you above all, the modest woman of our land, the country woman who believed in us, the mother who knew our concern for children. I address the youth, those who sang and gave us their joy and their spirit of struggle. I address the man of Chile, the worker, the farmer, the intellectual. Surely Radio Magallanes will be silenced and the calm metal of my voice will no longer reach you.
感谢您收听《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这想必是我最后一次向你们发表讲话的机会了。我首先要向我国的妇女们致辞，那些相信我们的乡村妇女，那些了解我们对孩子关切的母亲们。我要向青年们致辞，是你们歌唱并给予了我们欢乐和奋斗的精神。我要向智利的男人们致辞，向工人们、农民们、知识分子们致辞。麦哲伦电台（Radio Magallanes）想必会被迫噤声，我那平静的声音将无法再传达到你们耳中。
It does not matter. You will continue hearing it. I will always be next to you. At least my memory will be that of a man of dignity who was loyal to his country. Workers of my country, I have faith in Chile and its destiny. Other men will overcome this dark and bitter moment when treason seeks to prevail. Go forward knowing that sooner rather than later, the great avenues will open again, and free men will walk through them to construct a
没关系。你们会继续听到它的。我将永远陪伴在你们身边。至少，我的记忆将属于一个有尊严、忠于祖国的人。我国的工人们，我对智利及其命运充满信心。当叛乱试图占据上风时，其他人终将克服这一黑暗而痛苦的时刻。请继续前进，要知道迟早有一天，伟大的大道将再次敞开，自由的人们将走在上面，去建设一个
better society. Long live Chile. Long live the people. Long live the workers. These are my last words and I am certain that my sacrifice will not be in vain. So Dominic, as you well know, because you actually sent me that as part of your briefing notes, that was the last radio address of Salvador Allende, the president of Chile, on the 11th of September, 1973, hours before his death, before he was conclusively toppled in a coup led by General Pinochet. I mean, we'll discuss this because this is one of the many intriguing aspects of this story. It's a seismic episode, isn't it, in the history of Latin America, the toppling of Allende. It is.
更美好的社会。智利万岁。人民万岁。工人们万岁。这是我最后的遗言，我确信我的牺牲不会是徒劳的。那么，多米尼克，正如你所知，因为你确实在简报中提到了这一点，那是智利总统萨尔瓦多·阿连德于1973年9月11日，也就是他去世前几个小时，在皮诺切特将军领导的政变中被彻底推翻前，所发表的最后一次广播讲话。我的意思是，我们会讨论这个问题，因为这是这个故事中许多引人入胜的方面之一。这是一个震撼性的事件，不是吗？在拉丁美洲的历史上，阿连德的倒台。确实如此。
So, Tom, we are literally, I mean, we're recording this on the 11th of September, on the 50th anniversary of that day, the coup that toppled Allende's democratically elected socialist regime and brought General Pinochet to power. And there are lots of Latin American coups.
所以，汤姆，我们现在真的是在9月11日录制这期节目，也就是那场政变发生50周年纪念日，那场政变推翻了阿连德民选的社会主义政权，并将皮诺切特将军推上了权力宝座。拉丁美洲发生过很多次政变。
Well, we've covered some of them, haven't we? In Costa Rica, we've talked about. Costa Rican civil war. Or Uruguay in the 1970s. But this is often seen abroad as the textbook example of American imperialism, ruthlessness, the kind of sacrifice of principles in the Cold War. And people will often point the finger at Richard Nixon and particularly at Henry Kissinger. So Kissinger, who recently celebrated his 100th birthday. And as always, there was a sort of torrent of articles saying Kissinger is a war criminal,
嗯，我们已经讨论过其中一些了，不是吗？比如哥斯达黎加，我们谈到过哥斯达黎加内战。或者20世纪70年代的乌拉圭。但在国外，这通常被视为美国帝国主义、冷酷无情以及在冷战中牺牲原则的教科书式案例。人们经常会指责理查德·尼克松，尤其是亨利·基辛格。基辛格最近刚庆祝了他的100岁生日。和往常一样，出现了一连串的文章，称基辛格是战犯，
Kissinger is an evil man because of what he did in Chile. That shadow has hung over him and Nixon's reputation ever since 1973. You said we're recording this actually on September 11th, so 9-11. Do you think that the memory of this coup has been slightly blotted out, certainly in the English-speaking world, by the attack on the World Trade Center and the Pentagon and so on. There is a sort of very dark irony there, that the date that for Americans, you know, is the sort of- Lives in infamy.
基辛格是个恶人，因为他在智利所做的一切。自1973年以来，那道阴影一直笼罩着他和尼克松的名声。你说我们实际上是在9月11日录制这期节目，也就是“9·11”。你认为这场政变的记忆是否在某种程度上被世界贸易中心和五角大楼遇袭等事件所掩盖了，尤其是在英语世界？这里面有一种非常黑暗的讽刺，那个对美国人来说是……“国耻日”。
Lives in infamy, like Pearl Harbor. Often Chileans say, whoa, you know, September the 11th is our day of suffering, and your government was complicit in this. So there's definitely an irony there, I think, a grim irony for a lot of Chileans. And actually, I think outside in the English-speaking world, it is easy to underestimate the absolutely titanic resonance that this has in Chilean history, but also in Latin American history more generally, because of course, Pinochet's regime lasted till 1990. And the arguments about the economic experiment, but also about the death toll and the torture and whatnot under the general, I mean, those rumbled on and on, as we know, Tom, into British politics in the 1990s.
“国耻日”，就像珍珠港事件一样。智利人经常说，嘿，你知道，9月11日是我们受难的日子，而你们的政府是这场政变的共犯。所以我认为，这对许多智利人来说确实有一种残酷的讽刺意味。事实上，我认为在英语世界之外，人们很容易低估这件事在智利历史上，乃至在更广泛的拉丁美洲历史上所产生的巨大共鸣，因为皮诺切特的政权一直持续到了1990年。关于经济实验的争论，以及关于将军统治下的死亡人数、酷刑等等，正如我们所知，汤姆，这些争论一直持续到了20世纪90年代的英国政坛。
Yes. Actually, I mean, this coup had a huge impact on the way that people in certainly Britain and across Europe in the left thought about revolutionary politics in South America, but also its relationship with the United States. Exactly. So if you're, so, I mean, I don't know if he listens to the rest of his history, but the former Labour leader, Jeremy Corbyn, I don't know that he's a big fan of ours, is he, Tom?
是的。事实上，这场政变对英国乃至整个欧洲左翼人士思考南美革命政治的方式，以及它与美国的关系，产生了巨大的影响。没错。所以，如果他在听《历史余音》的话——我不知道他听不听——前工党领袖杰里米·科尔宾，我不知道他是不是我们的忠实粉丝，汤姆？
But- Who knows? I'd like to think so. He's the- Reaching all parts. He's exactly the kind of person who would bring up the Chilean coup unbidden and say, here is your textbook example of US imperial resonance, is that it can sometimes be hard to identify what the reality is. In this case, is the myth deserving of its status? Well, this is what I'm going to pick, I think, Tom. Let's start with the obvious sort of very basics. So let's start with Chile. Chile
但是——谁知道呢？我倒希望他是。他是那种……触及各个领域。他正是那种会主动提起智利政变，并说“这就是美国帝国主义的教科书式案例”的人。共鸣在于，有时很难确定真相到底是什么。在这种情况下，这个神话是否配得上它的地位？好吧，我想这就是我要选的话题，汤姆。让我们从最显而易见的基础开始。让我们从智利开始。智利
is the world's southernmost country. Obviously, famously, it's a very long and thin country, 3,000 miles long, only about, at its narrowest point, I think it's about 40 miles wide. The rest is geography. So it's a very strange looking country. It became independent from Spain in 1821, and for a long time was one of the poorest countries in the Latin American world. And that's with, is it Bernardo O'Higgins or something like that? Good knowledge, Tom. He's one of the absolute, he's the great hero of Chilean independence. The most Irish sounding liberator in South American history.
是世界上最南端的国家。显然，众所周知，它是一个非常狭长的国家，长3000英里，最窄处我想只有约40英里宽。剩下的就是地理了。所以这是一个看起来非常奇怪的国家。它于1821年从西班牙独立，长期以来是拉丁美洲最贫穷的国家之一。那是……是贝尔纳多·奥希金斯（Bernardo O'Higgins）之类的吗？知识很渊博，汤姆。他是智利独立运动的伟大英雄。他是南美历史上听起来最有爱尔兰气息的解放者。
There's lots of people like that in Latin America in the 19th century. But Chile became rich from mineral exports, particularly from copper. And copper makes it, by the end of the 19th century, one of the richest countries in what we would call the developing world. So like Argentina or Uruguay, it's seen at the end of the 19th century as a country that's likely to overtake a lot of European countries. And actually, most Latin American countries, their history in the 20th century is pretty bleak and conflicted, but not Chile.
19世纪的拉丁美洲有很多这样的人。但智利因矿产出口，特别是铜矿而变得富有。到19世纪末，铜矿使它成为我们所说的发展中国家中最富有的国家之一。所以就像阿根廷或乌拉圭一样，在19世纪末，它被视为一个很可能超越许多欧洲国家的国家。事实上，大多数拉丁美洲国家在20世纪的历史都相当凄凉且充满冲突，但智利并非如此。
Chile from the 1930s onwards is this kind of oasis of democratic stability. And there's no military intervention in politics. In fact, it's very important to Chile's sense of itself that, unlike in other countries, we don't have coups. The military don't intervene in politics. Because the military have been initially trained by Prussians. Is that right? Yes, that's right. And so they've instilled them a sense of importance of obeying orders, pursuit discipline, all that kind of thing. Loyalty to the state.
从20世纪30年代开始，智利就像是民主稳定的绿洲。政治中没有军事干预。事实上，智利自我认知中非常重要的一点是，与其他国家不同，我们没有政变。军队不干预政治。因为军队最初是由普鲁士人训练的。是这样吗？是的，没错。所以他们向军队灌输了一种服从命令、追求纪律等重要性的意识。对国家的忠诚。
Exactly right. Yeah, they're very kind of Bismarckian military. So this is all the background for the rise of our protagonist today. We'll talk about General Pinochet later. Let's start with the man he topples, the man you quoted, Tom. You were going to do it in a Chilean accent, but you were persuaded not to. So this is a guy who for many people is a martyr, if not a saint. So nice sacral element for you. Salvador Allende. So he's a figure from the great liberal tradition that, say, in Costa Rica,
完全正确。是的，他们是非常俾斯麦式的军队。所以这就是我们今天主角崛起的所有背景。我们稍后再谈皮诺切特将军。让我们从他推翻的那个人开始，也就是你引用的那个人，汤姆。你本来打算用智利口音来读，但被劝阻了。所以这是一个对许多人来说是烈士，甚至可以说是圣人的人。这对你来说是个不错的神圣元素。萨尔瓦多·阿连德。所以他是伟大自由主义传统中的一个人物，比如在哥斯达黎加，
one thinks of great liberal heroes, such as, say, Dr. Valverde, the martyr for Costa Rican democracy. Yes. Well, the end is further to the left, I think, than Dr. Valverde was, Tom. But he is, in a sense, the Dr. Valverde of Chile. Would you say? Would that be fair? I would go further than that, Tom. For people who haven't listened to our podcast about the Costa Rican civil War, they will have no idea what you're referring to. Everyone's heard of Dr. Valverde. Stop listening to this. Well, finish listening to this.
人们会想到伟大的自由主义英雄，比如瓦尔韦德医生（Dr. Valverde），哥斯达黎加民主的烈士。是的。嗯，阿连德比瓦尔韦德医生更偏左，汤姆。但在某种意义上，他是智利的瓦尔韦德医生。你会这么说吗？这公平吗？我会比这更进一步，汤姆。对于那些没听过我们关于哥斯达黎加内战播客的人来说，他们根本不知道你在指什么。每个人都听说过瓦尔韦德医生。别听这个了。好吧，听完这个再说。
Listen to Costa Rican Civil War. But Allende was born in 1908 in Santiago. He is from an upper middle class family, very reformist, very liberal, as you say. So his father had opened one of the first kind of secular schools in Chile. He was good at sport. Ayande, you'll be pleased to hear he's an elite sportsman himself, Tom. He was a member of the Everton de Viña del Mar. Yeah, that's brilliant, isn't it?
去听《哥斯达黎加内战》。但阿连德于1908年出生在圣地亚哥。他来自一个中上层家庭，非常改良主义，非常自由主义，正如你所说。所以他的父亲在智利创办了最早的世俗学校之一。他擅长体育。阿连德，你会很高兴听到他自己也是一名精英运动员，汤姆。他是埃弗顿德比尼亚德尔马（Everton de Viña del Mar）俱乐部的成员。是的，那太棒了，不是吗？
Named after. I love Everton. So named after Everton. Named after Everton. And then in the 1920s, he is a medical student at the University of Chile in Santiago. He's a student activist. So he's kind of the representative of the medical students and then students generally. in Santiago. He's a student activist. So he's kind of the representative of the medical students and then students generally.
以……命名。我喜欢埃弗顿。所以是以埃弗顿命名的。以埃弗顿命名。然后在20世纪20年代，他是圣地亚哥智利大学的医学生。他是一名学生积极分子。所以他算是医学生乃至圣地亚哥全体学生的代表。他是一名学生积极分子。所以他算是医学生乃至圣地亚哥全体学生的代表。
So does he become a doctor? He does. Yeah, absolutely. So he is Dr. Allende? Yeah. So the parallels with Dr. Valverde really are quite strong. Very good, Tom. So he's an anematopathologist. I don't know what that is, but he's that anyway. He wrote a doctoral thesis called Crime and Mental Hygiene, very kind of early 20th century subject. He's also, Tom, this will please you, he's a Freemason.
那么他成为医生了吗？是的，当然。所以他是阿连德医生？是的。所以与瓦尔韦德医生的相似之处确实非常强烈。非常好，汤姆。所以他是一名解剖病理学家。我不知道那是什么，但他确实是。他写了一篇名为《犯罪与心理卫生》的博士论文，是非常20世纪初的主题。而且，汤姆，这会让你高兴，他是一名共济会成员。
That doesn't really please me. Doesn't it? I thought you were all over links with previous podcasts. You're not a Freemason yourself, but you like to see it. No, I'll be honest, I think it's a waste of time. Oh my word, crikey. I think Freemasons would be better off playing cricket or something. Though obviously that wouldn't have been a possibility for Allende, would it? I bet you.
那并不能让我高兴。是吗？我以为你很喜欢与之前的播客建立联系。你自己不是共济会成员，但你喜欢看到这一点。不，老实说，我认为那是浪费时间。天哪，哎呀。我认为共济会成员还不如去打板球什么的。虽然显然这对阿连德来说是不可能的，对吧？我敢打赌。
Maybe there's a cricket club, probably Everton. I bet you there's some kind of cricket club. The Everton Football and Cricket Club. Exactly. So he gets very involved in socialist politics in the 1930s. He actually helps to set up a branch of the Socialist Party of Chile in Valparaiso, which is on the coast where he is based. And he becomes the union leader.
也许有个板球俱乐部，可能是埃弗顿。我敢打赌肯定有某种板球俱乐部。埃弗顿足球和板球俱乐部。没错。所以他在20世纪30年代非常积极地参与社会主义政治。他实际上帮助在瓦尔帕莱索（Valparaiso）建立了智利社会党的一个分支，那是他所在的沿海城市。他成为了工会领袖。
With somebody called Marmaduke Grove. Yes. That sounds improbable. Where's that come from? Well, it's actually Marmaduke. Grove. Yeah, Grove. I don't know anything about Marmaduke Grove. As with Dr. Valverde, Tom, let your imagination run riot. I see him as being ramrod back, very austere, very honourable. He's probably an Anglophile.
和一个叫马马杜克·格罗夫（Marmaduke Grove）的人一起。是的。这听起来不太可能。那是从哪儿冒出来的？嗯，实际上是马马杜克。格罗夫。是的，格罗夫。我对马马杜克·格罗夫一无所知。就像对待瓦尔韦德医生一样，汤姆，让你的想象力尽情驰骋吧。我把他想象成背部挺得笔直，非常严谨，非常光荣。他可能是一个亲英派。
He probably wears excellent tailoring that he orders in from Savile Row. Tweed. Yes. I think he probably smokes a pipe and later corresponds with Borges about his short stories. Yes. Okay, so that's Marmaduke Grove. Right.
他可能穿着从萨维尔街（Savile Row）定制的精美西装。粗花呢。是的。我想他可能抽着烟斗，后来还和博尔赫斯通信讨论他的短篇小说。是的。好吧，那就是马马杜克·格罗夫。没错。
I didn't expect the podcast to take this turn, I have to say. I don't think there's any other podcasts about General Pinochet that have begun in this manner. Allende becomes Minister of Health in the late 1930s. He becomes a senator. He helps to establish Chile's National Health Service. So this is before British National Health Service? No, afterwards, 1950s. Ah, okay.
我必须说，我没想到播客会变成这样。我不认为还有其他关于皮诺切特将军的播客是以这种方式开头的。阿连德在20世纪30年代末成为卫生部长。他成为了一名参议员。他帮助建立了智利的国家医疗服务体系。所以这是在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）之前？不，是在之后，20世纪50年代。啊，好吧。
And is that inspired by the British example or not? I don't think so. Maybe I'm wrong. I'm wondering whether Marmaduke Grove's anglophilia maybe is kicking in. Who knows? Whether like Anirin Bevan, the founder of Britain's NHS, he'd grown up with a Greyfriars stories, Tom. Do you think that's possibly the case? Chilean history, we've got it. Right, listen, the big thing about Allende is Allende becomes this great organiser on the case. Chilean history, we've got it. Right, listen, the big thing about Allende is Allende becomes this great organiser on the left. You used the word liberal earlier. He's more than
那是受英国的例子启发吗？我不这么认为。也许我错了。我在想马马杜克·格罗夫的亲英倾向是否在起作用。谁知道呢？就像英国NHS的创始人安奈林·贝文（Aneurin Bevan）一样，他是在《格雷弗莱尔》（Greyfriars）的故事中长大的，汤姆。你认为这有可能吗？智利历史，我们搞定了。好吧，听着，关于阿连德最重要的一点是，阿连德成为了左翼伟大的组织者。你刚才用了“自由主义”这个词。他不仅仅是
a liberal. He is a full card-carrying socialist. He's a Marxist. He's a Marxist intellectual. Okay, but socialists aren't necessarily Marxists. No, but he is a Marxist. He is a Marxist, okay. He is a Marxist, but of a relatively... He's never seen as on the sort of more extreme fire breathing end of the spectrum. A kind of Italian communist? Yes. He wants to come to power by parliamentary means. There's no hint of kind of revolutionary paramilitary politics or anything like that with him. You know, he's in the Senate, he's on committees, he's on kind of panels and- He doesn't want to abolish democracy no there's no hint of that
一个自由主义者。他是一个持证的社会主义者。他是一个马克思主义者。他是一个马克思主义知识分子。好吧，但社会主义者不一定是马克思主义者。不，但他是一个马克思主义者。他是一个马克思主义者，好吧。他是一个马克思主义者，但相对……他从未被视为光谱中更极端、更激进的那一端。一种意大利式的共产主义者？是的。他想通过议会手段上台。他身上没有任何革命准军事政治的迹象。你知道，他在参议院，他在委员会，他在各种小组里——他不想废除民主，不，没有那种迹象。
at this never hint at any end of that no so he makes three unsuccessful bids for the presidency in 1952 1958 1964 and he keeps losing and he actually jokes with again a grim irony he says you know on my on my tombstone it will say here lies the next president of chile because he keeps losing yeah so 1952 he actually only won 5% of the vote. In 1958, he does a lot better. He wins 28.5% of the vote. It's almost a third. And here's the interesting thing.
从来没有那种迹象，不。所以他在1952年、1958年、1964年三次竞选总统均告失败，他一直在输。他甚至开玩笑说，又是一个残酷的讽刺，他说：“你知道，在我的墓碑上会写着：这里躺着智利的下一任总统。”因为他一直在输。是的，所以1952年他实际上只赢得了5%的选票。1958年，他表现好多了。他赢得了28.5%的选票。几乎是三分之一。有趣的事情来了。
Even at this stage, the Americans are very worried about Allende. So in the early 1960s, Allende is clearly, you know, he's gearing up for another run of the presidency. That will be in 1964 because it's a six-year term. And that means the administration in Washington is the Kennedy administration. Now, the Kennedy administration, in a break with previous American administration, with Eisenhower, Kennedy and his chums say, listen, we've always backed the most oligarchic, conservative, repressive kind of people in Latin America. They've been our allies. We shouldn't be doing this. To stop Marxism, to stop communism and the rise of the left and Fidel Castro types, we should actually back reformist parties of the center, center-right, so Christian Democrat type people. And in Chile, they identify a guy called Eduardo Fry. And actually, he comes and visits the White House and the CIA. They start to pump money into Chile, as they are doing in so many other countries, to support the Christian Democrat centre-right Fry. And they spend about $2.5 million giving him direct money. But in Chile, with its kind of democratic traditions, is there a kind of very hard right junta that's been in power?
即使在这个阶段，美国人也非常担心阿连德。所以在20世纪60年代初，阿连德显然是在为下一次总统竞选做准备。那将是在1964年，因为任期是六年。这意味着华盛顿的政府是肯尼迪政府。现在，肯尼迪政府打破了之前美国政府（艾森豪威尔政府）的惯例，肯尼迪和他的伙伴们说：“听着，我们一直支持拉丁美洲最寡头、最保守、最压迫的人。他们一直是我们的盟友。我们不应该这样做。为了阻止马克思主义，阻止共产主义和左翼的崛起以及菲德尔·卡斯特罗这类人，我们实际上应该支持中间派、中右翼的改良主义政党，比如基督教民主党人。”在智利，他们确定了一个叫爱德华多·弗雷（Eduardo Frei）的人。他实际上访问了白宫和中央情报局。他们开始像在其他许多国家一样，向智利注入资金，以支持基督教民主党的中右翼弗雷。他们花了大约250万美元直接资助他。但在智利，凭借其民主传统，是否有极右翼军政府掌权？
No, no, there isn't. There are right-wing, pro-business, kind of oligarchic parties. Right, okay. But in a mass democracy, the Americans recognise, listen, there's no point us backing the most right-wing party because they're probably not going to win. We should back a party of the centre-right who will carry out reforms because that's the best way to beat communism, to show that centre politics
不，没有。有右翼、亲商业、寡头式的政党。好吧，明白了。但在大众民主中，美国人认识到，听着，我们支持最右翼的政党毫无意义，因为他们很可能赢不了。我们应该支持一个中右翼政党，他们会进行改革，因为这是击败共产主义的最佳方式，证明中间派政治
can deliver. And presumably they're particularly sensitive to this in the early 60s because they've got the tension between Kennedy's progressivism and the fact that they've got the Cuban revolution on their doorstep. Exactly. They're obsessed with Cuba. The Kennedy administration was completely fixated on Cuba. They'd been humiliated in the failed Bay of Pigs invasion. Of course, you'd had the Cuban missile crisis in 1962. Cuban exiles in the United States are very vociferous about their failure to topple Castro. And the Kennedy administration are desperate not to, as they would describe it, lose another Latin American country to Marxism. So they spend about $3 million on anti-Allende propaganda within Chile. We know this from the committee hearings on radio programs, on pamphlets, on leaflets, even kind of paintings in the streets, kind of wall painting, murals, all of this stuff.
能够带来成果。而且大概他们在60年代初对这一点特别敏感，因为他们面临着肯尼迪的进步主义与古巴革命就在家门口这一事实之间的紧张关系。没错。他们对古巴着了迷。肯尼迪政府完全专注于古巴。他们在失败的猪湾入侵中受到了羞辱。当然，1962年还发生了古巴导弹危机。在美国的古巴流亡者对他们未能推翻卡斯特罗感到非常愤怒。肯尼迪政府拼命不想，用他们的话说，再失去一个拉丁美洲国家给马克思主义。所以他们在智利境内花费了大约300万美元进行反阿连德宣传。我们从国会听证会上得知，这些钱用于广播节目、小册子、传单，甚至街头的绘画、墙画、壁画，所有这些东西。
Now, as the election approaches 1964, Kennedy is, of course, dead. Lyndon Johnson continues this effort. We know that his Secretary of State, Dean Rusk, wrote to him in 1964 as follows. We are making a major covert effort to reduce the chances of Chile becoming the first American country to elect an avowed Marxist president. Our well-concealed program embraces special assistance, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So the Americans, I mean, among themselves, they're completely upfront about this and it works. Allende loses in 1964 to Eduardo Frey. And how important do you think the influence of the American support for Allende's opponents are?
现在，随着1964年选举的临近，肯尼迪当然已经去世了。林登·约翰逊继续这项努力。我们知道他的国务卿迪恩·腊斯克（Dean Rusk）在1964年写信给他，内容如下：“我们正在进行一项重大的秘密行动，以减少智利成为第一个选举出公开的马克思主义总统的美洲国家的可能性。我们精心掩盖的计划包括特殊援助，等等等等。”所以美国人在他们内部对此完全是直言不讳的，而且它奏效了。阿连德在1964年输给了爱德华多·弗雷。你认为美国对阿连德对手的支持影响有多大？
It is important. I think it's pretty important. Of course, it's very hard to say would Allende have won without that. I mean, of course, he does end up winning six years later, which we'll come to. So, and the Americans make
这很重要。我认为这相当重要。当然，很难说如果没有这些，阿连德是否会赢。我的意思是，当然，他最终在六年后的确赢了，我们稍后会谈到。所以，美国人做出了
even more of an effort then, but it doesn't work. So one thing that I think is really important to get across is the Americans are not omnipotent. They, you know, they have allies in Chile and without the allies, they wouldn't get anywhere. So the idea, just as a spoiler alert, the idea that the whole of Chilean politics is just a kind of playground for interfering Americans, the Americans are puppet masters
更大的努力，但没有奏效。所以我认为有一点非常重要，那就是美国人并非无所不能。他们，你知道，他们在智利有盟友，没有这些盟友，他们将一事无成。所以，作为一个剧透，认为整个智利政治只是干涉的美国人的游乐场，美国人是木偶大师，
and the Chileans don't have any agency themselves, I think is wrong. I mean, paradoxically, that is the opinion that's very much there on the hard left, I guess, of European politics. Yeah. That it overestimates American power. It does indeed. Anyway, Aena didn't win in 64. Christian Democrat guy won.
而智利人自己没有任何能动性，我认为是错误的。我的意思是，矛盾的是，这正是欧洲政治极左翼的观点。是的。这高估了美国的力量。确实如此。总之，阿连德在64年没赢。基督教民主党人赢了。
The Americans pumped in loads of money. They pumped in more money into Chile than any other country in Latin America. So about more than a billion dollars between 1962 and 1970. And quite a lot of money to the Chilean military. So they start to establish big links with the Chilean military. And they're putting money into anti-Allende campaigns because yet again, Allende, who just keeps losing elections, says, I'd like to run again in 1970. It's important to stress Allende is a Marxist, but he's seen as being on the sort of more moderate side of that spectrum. So there are people who are further left to the left than Allende. It's important for people to get that into their minds.
美国人注入了大量资金。他们向智利注入的资金比拉丁美洲任何其他国家都多。所以从1962年到1970年超过了10亿美元。而且有相当多的钱给了智利军方。所以他们开始与智利军方建立密切联系。他们把钱投入到反阿连德运动中，因为阿连德又一次，他只是不断地输掉选举，说：“我想在1970年再次参选。”强调阿连德是马克思主义者很重要，但他被视为该光谱中比较温和的一面。所以有些人比阿连德更偏左。让人们意识到这一点很重要。
He's not as terrifying a figure to the conservative middle classes as other people might be. He's not Castro. No, he's not Castro. He's not Castro at all. It's the fact that he keeps losing. This doesn't kind of brand him a serial loser on the left. They're happy to continue supporting him, are they? They still think that he's their best candidate. Yeah, they think he's well-known, he's popular. The image of being a kind of kindly doctor,
对于保守的中产阶级来说，他不像其他人那样是一个可怕的人物。他不是卡斯特罗。不，他不是卡斯特罗。他根本不是卡斯特罗。他只是因为不断输掉选举。这并没有给他贴上左翼“连败者”的标签。他们很高兴继续支持他，是吗？他们仍然认为他是他们最好的候选人。是的，他们认为他很有名，很受欢迎。那种和蔼可亲的医生的形象，
which he has, kind of cerebral doctor, that plays well. And they sort of think he's the man, and eventually one day he'll get over the line. And this is looking quite likely in 1970. And the people who are particularly alarmed about this are American business interests. So I mentioned copper before. There are two big American copper companies, Anaconda and Kennecott Copper. And there's also ITT, the International Telephone and Telegraph Company, one of America's biggest companies. And they have $200 million in holdings in Chile. They own a large proportion of the
他所拥有的那种理性的医生形象，很受欢迎。他们认为他是那个人，最终有一天他会跨过终点线。这在1970年看起来很有可能。而对此特别警惕的是美国的商业利益。所以我之前提到了铜矿。有两家大型美国铜业公司，安纳康达（Anaconda）和肯尼科特铜业（Kennecott Copper）。还有ITT，国际电话电报公司，美国最大的公司之一。他们在智利有2亿美元的资产。他们拥有
Chilean telephone company. This is really important. They fund a really big Chilean newspaper called El Mercurio, right-wing newspaper. They own hotels, all these kinds of things. And they are plowing money into the election in 1970, giving money to his conservative opponent, his guy called Alessandri. But they're also talking to the new administration in Washington, which is Richard Nixon's administration. So Richard Nixon and Henry Kissinger, and ITT in particular, are saying to them, you can't let this guy win. This guy is a Marxist. It runs against everything we believe in. We're embroiled in Vietnam. America's going to be humiliated again somewhere else, all of this stuff.
智利电话公司很大一部分股份。这非常重要。他们资助了一家非常大的智利报纸《信使报》（El Mercurio），这是一份右翼报纸。他们拥有酒店，所有这些东西。他们在1970年的选举中投入了大量资金，给他的保守派对手，一个叫亚历山德里（Alessandri）的人。但他们也在与华盛顿的新政府，也就是理查德·尼克松的政府交谈。所以理查德·尼克松和亨利·基辛格，特别是ITT，在对他们说：“你们不能让这家伙赢。这家伙是个马克思主义者。这违背了我们所相信的一切。我们卷入了越南战争。美国又要被羞辱了，所有这些东西。”
But they're basically saying this because they don't want to lose their money. I mean, that's the bottom line. Well, they don't want to lose their money, of course. Yes. We know now from an amazing stash of declassified documents, which have been published by a guy, a historian called Peter Kornbluh in his book, The Pinnacle File. So these documents have been declassified and they're all online. If you go to the National Security Archive run by George Washington University, you can see them all that in the summer of 1970 the election is going to
但他们基本上这么说是因为他们不想赔钱。我的意思是，这就是底线。嗯，他们当然不想赔钱。是的。我们现在从一大堆解密文件中得知了这一点，这些文件由一位名叫彼得·科恩布鲁（Peter Kornbluh）的历史学家在他的书《皮诺切特档案》（The Pinochet File）中发表。所以这些文件已经被解密，并且都在网上。如果你去乔治华盛顿大学的国家安全档案馆，你可以看到所有这些。在1970年的夏天，选举将在
be in the autumn in the summer of 1970 richard nixon and henry kissinger are already talking about iron day winning and whether or not they should try to ferment a coup so an amazing quotation the 27th of june can i read it are you going to read it as Henry Kissinger? I don't see why we need to stand behind what a country go communist due to the irresponsibility of its people. The issues are much too important
秋天举行。在1970年的夏天，理查德·尼克松和亨利·基辛格已经在谈论阿连德获胜的可能性，以及他们是否应该尝试煽动政变。这是一个惊人的引语，6月27日的，我可以读一下吗？你要用亨利·基辛格的口吻读吗？“我不明白为什么我们要坐视一个国家因为其人民的不负责任而走向共产主义。这些问题太重要了，
for the Chilean voters to be left to decide for themselves. So that was Arnold Schwarzenegger. It wasn't. It was obviously Kissinger. I mean, that's an amazing, amazing quotation.
不能留给智利选民自己决定。”所以那是阿诺·施瓦辛格。不是。显然是基辛格。我的意思是，那是一个令人震惊的引语。
To talk about the irresponsibility of its people and all this. Allende actually wins. He wins by 36% to 35% over Alessandri because there's a split vote. Now, when there's a split vote and nobody has an absolute majority, the Congress will choose the winner. And the tradition is that the Chilean Congress will always choose the person who got the biggest vote. That's fair enough, I think. Yeah, it's absolutely fair. Yeah. Surely even Kissinger couldn't oppose that. No. So Allende is actually going to win. So we know, again, from these declassified documents, that on the 15th of September, 1970, in that afternoon, Nixon has a meeting with Henry Kissinger, his Attorney General John Mitchell, familiar to fans of Watergate, and the director of the CIA, Richard Helms.
谈论其人民的不负责任等等。阿连德实际上赢了。他以36%对35%的优势战胜了亚历山德里，因为选票分散了。现在，当选票分散且没有人获得绝对多数时，国会将选择获胜者。传统是智利国会总是选择得票最多的人。我认为这很公平。是的，这绝对公平。是的。肯定连基辛格都无法反对这一点。不。所以阿连德实际上要赢了。所以我们再次从这些解密文件中得知，1970年9月15日下午，尼克松与亨利·基辛格、他的司法部长约翰·米切尔（水门事件粉丝很熟悉）、中央情报局局长理查德·赫尔姆斯（Richard Helms）举行了会议。
And we have Helms' handwritten notes. Tom, do you want to read the handwritten notes? A one in 10 chance, perhaps, but save Chile. Worth spending, not concerned risks involved, no involvement of embassy, $10 million available more if necessary, full-time job, best men we have, game plan, make economy scream, 48 hours for plan of job. Best men we have. Game plan. Make economy scream. 48 hours for plan of action. So there you have it. Make economy scream. So basically, their plan is they want to somehow subvert the election, and they're trying to think of ways to do it.
我们有赫尔姆斯的手写笔记。汤姆，你想读一下手写笔记吗？“十分之一的机会，也许，但要拯救智利。值得花费，不担心涉及的风险，不涉及大使馆，1000万美元可用，如有必要更多，全职工作，我们最好的手下，行动计划，让经济尖叫，48小时内拿出行动计划。”我们最好的手下。行动计划。让经济尖叫。48小时内拿出行动计划。所以这就是了。让经济尖叫。所以基本上，他们的计划是他们想以某种方式颠覆选举，他们正在想办法做到这一点。
Now, before we massively beat up on Nixon and Kissinger, other American administrations have done similar things. So in 1954, Eisenhower had approved a coup to overthrow the elected government in Guatemala. There was a threat to the American United Fruit Company, Tom. Can't have that. And of course, Kennedy had all the time now been trying to support action against Castro and Cuba. Of course, the difference is Castro isn't democratically elected. But the idea of Americans using the CIA to overthrow Latin American regimes, that predates Nixon and Kissinger. But this is the first time they have done it in a big country like Chile, which is clearly devoted to its kind of democratic tradition. And they have two ideas.
现在，在我们大规模抨击尼克松和基辛格之前，其他美国政府也做过类似的事情。所以1954年，艾森豪威尔批准了一场政变，推翻了危地马拉的民选政府。这对美国的联合果品公司（United Fruit Company）构成了威胁，汤姆。不能那样。当然，肯尼迪一直以来都在试图支持针对卡斯特罗和古巴的行动。当然，区别在于卡斯特罗不是民选的。但美国利用中央情报局推翻拉丁美洲政权的想法，在尼克松和基辛格之前就存在了。但这是他们第一次在智利这样的大国这样做，智利显然致力于其民主传统。他们有两个想法。
One is called track one. We don't need to massively go into that. Basically, that is, they will somehow bribe or persuade the Chilean Congress not to vote for Allende. They decide that's not going to work. And the other is what they call track two, and that is basically to have a coup. And the way they will do that is they will persuade the Chilean military to have a coup because they will basically tell them, if you don't do this, we will, as you said from Helms' notes, make the economy scream. And Nixon says, he tells his aides, start cutting off loans, put pressure on banks to cancel their loans to Chile, get the banks to downgrade Chile's credit rating. Basically, all of this is a massive warning to the Chilean military. The problem they face is that the Chilean military have this tradition of non-interference
一个是所谓的“轨道一”（Track one）。我们不需要深入探讨。基本上，那是他们将以某种方式贿赂或说服智利国会不要投票给阿连德。他们决定那行不通。另一个是他们所谓的“轨道二”（Track two），基本上就是发动政变。他们实现这一目标的方式是说服智利军方发动政变，因为他们基本上会告诉他们：“如果你不这样做，我们就会，正如你从赫尔姆斯的笔记中所说，让经济尖叫。”尼克松告诉他的助手：“开始切断贷款，向银行施压，取消对智利的贷款，让银行下调智利的信用评级。”基本上，所有这些都是对智利军方的一个巨大警告。他们面临的问题是，智利军方有不干预政治的传统。
in politics. And their commander-in-chief of the Chilean military is a guy called Rene Schneider. He has had a meeting of his staff that summer in July 1970. He has made it absolutely clear to them, we will not interfere in politics. That is not our job. It's not what we do in Chile. You know, other countries do it in Latin America, but we are the guardians of the constitution. The Americans say, the ambassador actually, it's actually the American ambassador who comes up with this idea, a guy called Edward Corrie. He says, if we just get rid of this bloke
而智利军方的总司令是一个叫雷内·施耐德（Rene Schneider）的人。他在1970年7月那个夏天召开了参谋会议。他向他们明确表示：“我们不会干预政治。那不是我们的工作。这不是我们在智利所做的事情。你知道，其他国家在拉丁美洲会这样做，但我们是宪法的守护者。”美国人说，大使，实际上是美国大使想出了这个主意，一个叫爱德华·科里（Edward Corrie）的人。他说：“如果我们除掉这个家伙，
who's the commander in chief, maybe the others will fall into line because he knows. Now, this is a really interesting thing. Because the Chilean military have not been involved in politics, they're actually worse paid than army officers in other Latin American countries because they don't have the same kind of stake in politics. They don't have the same capital, as it were. So they can't afford dark glasses and massive braid on their uniforms and big hats. Yes, exactly. And actually, in 1969, there'd already been something called the Tacnazo, where the artillery barracks, there'd been a mutiny about their low pay.
也就是总司令，也许其他人会顺从，因为他知道。”现在，这是一件非常有趣的事情。因为智利军方没有参与政治，他们的薪水实际上比其他拉丁美洲国家的军官要低，因为他们在政治中没有同样的利益。他们没有同样的资本。所以他们买不起深色墨镜、制服上巨大的编织物和大帽子。是的，完全正确。而且事实上，1969年已经发生过所谓的“塔克纳佐”（Tacnazo）事件，炮兵营因为低薪发生了兵变。
So the Americans say, listen, there's a lot of discontent in the Chilean ministry. If we can just get rid of General Schneider, maybe we can persuade them to interfere in the election. They find these guys and they make two attempts to kidnap Schneider and basically neutralize him in some way. When they make their third attempt, which is October 1970, a couple of days before the Congress is due to vote on INende, Schneider fights back. So there's a sort of gun fight and he is shot and killed. This wasn't quite what the Americans were planning.
所以美国人说：“听着，智利军方有很多不满。如果我们能除掉施耐德将军，也许我们可以说服他们干预选举。”他们找到了这些人，并两次试图绑架施耐德，基本上以某种方式让他中立。当他们进行第三次尝试时，也就是1970年10月，在国会预定投票给阿连德的前几天，施耐德进行了反击。所以发生了一场枪战，他被枪杀身亡。这并不是美国人计划的那样。
And the guys who are trying to kidnap him, they are posing as kind of leftist terrorists. Yes, they're going to frame the left and use that as an excuse to kind of cancel the election. Well, this doesn't work at all. Schneider is shot. There's a great outpouring of sort of shock. And two days later, Allende does a deal with the Congress. He says, I promise I will guarantee the Chilean constitution. It's not going to be Fidel Castro style. I'll be a democratic politician.
而那些试图绑架他的人，他们伪装成左翼恐怖分子。是的，他们要嫁祸给左翼，并以此为借口取消选举。嗯，这根本没用。施耐德被枪杀了。人们表现出了巨大的震惊。两天后，阿连德与国会达成了一项协议。他说：“我承诺我将保证智利宪法。这不会是菲德尔·卡斯特罗式的。我将成为一名民主政治家。”
And they overwhelmingly vote to ratify him as the winner of the election. And so it is that on the 3rd of November 1970, Allende becomes president of Chile. Well, Dominic, I think that we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's see whether Allende hits the ground running as president. So we'll be back very soon. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
他们以压倒性多数投票批准他为选举获胜者。因此，1970年11月3日，阿连德成为智利总统。好吧，多米尼克，我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看阿连德作为总统是否一帆风顺。所以我们很快就会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的娱乐新闻修复，
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
评论，一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are recording this on the 11th of September,
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余音》。我们是在9月11日录制这期节目，
the 50th anniversary of the coup against President Allende of Chile and Dominic. Allende has just become president on the 3rd of November 1970. Just very, very quickly before we come to what he did as president, looking back at the American attempts to stop him becoming president. So trying to spawn the military, using lots of money to bribe people, using right-wing press. I mean, these are the nightmares of people on the left about US interference, not just in Latin America, but in Europe as well. I remember there was a book by Chris Mullen, who I think was Sunderland MP, which was a very British coup, which kind of imagined, I guess, a kind of Jeremy Corbyn-type prime minister coming to power and being overthrown in exactly the way that, I mean,
也就是针对智利阿连德总统政变50周年纪念日，多米尼克。阿连德刚刚在1970年11月3日成为总统。在谈到他作为总统所做的事情之前，非常非常简短地回顾一下美国阻止他成为总统的尝试。所以试图煽动军队，利用大量资金贿赂人们，利用右翼媒体。我的意思是，这些是左翼人士对美国干涉的噩梦，不仅在拉丁美洲，在欧洲也是如此。我记得克里斯·马伦（Chris Mullen）写过一本书，我想他是桑德兰的议员，书名是《非常英国的政变》（A Very British Coup），它想象了一个杰里米·科尔宾式的首相上台，并以完全相同的方式被推翻，我的意思是，
it sounds very, very reminiscent of the way that the Americans tried to operate against the end. Presumably that is not a coincidence. No, it's not a coincidence, Tom. All of this casts a shadow over the left across the West. It does, absolutely. So Chris Mullen is absolutely one of that generation of British left-wingers who were very strongly influenced by what happened in Chile, and are thinking about it a lot in the 1970s and 1980s. There's lots of talk about coups from the mid-70s through to the mid-80s when Mullen writes his book, and then it's on TV. The prime minister is called Harry Perkins. He's played in the TV version by Ray McAnally.
这听起来非常非常让人想起美国人试图对付阿连德的方式。大概那不是巧合。不，那不是巧合，汤姆。所有这一切都在西方左翼身上投下了阴影。确实如此，绝对。所以克里斯·马伦绝对是那一代深受智利事件影响的英国左翼人士之一，他们在20世纪70年代和80年代对此思考了很多。从70年代中期到80年代中期马伦写书时，有很多关于政变的讨论，然后它出现在电视上。首相叫哈里·珀金斯（Harry Perkins）。他在电视版中由雷·麦卡纳利（Ray McAnally）饰演。
And it's exactly that. There's always this image that you see in all these kind of Ken Loach type films and whatnot of the sort of shadowy hand at the US embassy picking up a phone and saying, get me MI6 or whatever it might be. And the following morning, a fake news story in the newspaper that destroys the left-wing candidates or something. The Americans had already employed techniques like this before, by the way, in Italy, and I guess in places like Greece in the late 1940s, early 1950s. So if you'd asked them, what's your justification for doing it? You'd ask Helms, Kissinger, or indeed Kennedy or Eisenhower. Fighting communism. They would have said exactly that. They would have said, listen, this isn't the Vicarage Tea Party. We're in a fight to the death with world communism. They use the techniques of dissimulation and deception and so on to beat them.
而且完全就是那样。在所有这些肯·洛奇（Ken Loach）式的电影等等中，你总是看到那种形象：美国大使馆里有一只阴影之手拿起电话说：“给我接军情六处（MI6）”或者其他什么。第二天早上，报纸上的一篇假新闻摧毁了左翼候选人什么的。顺便说一句，美国人之前已经在意大利，我想还有40年代末、50年代初的希腊使用过类似的技术。所以如果你问他们，你这样做的理由是什么？你会问赫尔姆斯、基辛格，或者肯尼迪或艾森豪威尔。打击共产主义。他们会完全那样说。他们会说：“听着，这不是牧师茶会。我们正在与世界共产主义进行殊死搏斗。”他们使用伪装和欺骗等技术来击败他们。
I mean, this is the moral dilemma at the heart of John le Carré's novels. To beat them, sometimes you have to use their own techniques against them. I mean, that's what they would have said. And that's the sort of shadow that hangs over this. Okay. I slightly diverted you from saying what Allende does when he becomes president. So 100 days, does it go well? It's an extraordinary start, actually. So when Allende comes in, in November 1970,
我的意思是，这是约翰·勒卡雷（John le Carré）小说核心的道德困境。为了击败他们，有时你必须使用他们自己的技术来对付他们。我的意思是，这就是他们会说的。这就是笼罩在这一切之上的阴影。好吧。我稍微偏离了让你说阿连德成为总统后做了什么。所以100天，进展顺利吗？实际上是一个非凡的开始。所以当阿连德在1970年11月上任时，
he has, as I said, he's actually been approved by the Christian Democratic representation in the Congress. He has signed this thing saying he will uphold the Chilean constitution. Although he's a Marxist, he won't scrap it. But it's a blizzard of change and legislation. I mean, we can't go through it all. But he announces we are going to nationalize or continue and complete the nationalization of the big industries in Chile, notably the banking system and copper, of course. He announces tons of new spending on health and on education. Program of free milk for children, I see. Yeah.
正如我所说，他实际上已经得到了国会中基督教民主党代表的批准。他签署了一份文件，承诺维护智利宪法。尽管他是马克思主义者，但他不会废除宪法。但这简直是一场变革和立法的暴风雪。我的意思是，我们无法一一详述。但他宣布我们将要国有化，或者继续并完成智利大工业的国有化，特别是银行系统和铜矿。他宣布在医疗和教育方面投入大量新资金。我看到还有为儿童提供免费牛奶的计划。是的。
Just at the time that Mrs. Thatcher was abolishing that in Britain. She is. She is. Mrs. Thatcher, the milk snatcher, as she was called. I think very unfairly, actually, Tom, because she was actually continuing what had started in the 1960s. However, that is a subject for another podcast. But he also wants to massively expand land redistribution.
就在撒切尔夫人在英国废除这项计划的时候。确实如此。撒切尔夫人，也就是人们所说的“牛奶掠夺者”。汤姆，我认为这其实很不公平，因为她实际上是在延续60年代就开始的政策。不过，那是另一个播客的主题。但他还希望大规模扩大土地再分配。
Of course, always a huge issue in Latin America because the Spanish Empire left a grossly unequal system of land ownership. Lots of things like scholarships for Mapuche Indian children, social security, amnesties for political prisoners, tax relief for the very poorest taxpayers, sending out tens of thousands of volunteers into the countryside. Now, these volunteers will often be students, young people who are full of socialist enthusiasm. They will go out into the countryside on a kind of mass literacy campaign to teach reading and writing. There's a new minimum wage.
当然，这在拉丁美洲一直是一个巨大的问题，因为西班牙帝国留下了一个极其不平等的土地所有权制度。还有很多项目，比如为马普切印第安儿童提供奖学金、社会保障、政治犯大赦、为最贫困的纳税人减税，以及向农村派遣数以万计的志愿者。这些志愿者通常是学生，是充满社会主义热情的年轻人。他们将深入农村，开展某种大规模的扫盲运动，教人们识字。此外还有一个新的最低工资标准。
There's free school meals. And he does all this within weeks i mean basically it's like a left-wing wish list and he's going to do everything so very like this like the starmer government when it comes to power do you think so land redistribution tom i haven't exciting new beginning and there is also there was another element to this which is i think one of the reasons why the aende uh why aende has become such a sort of saint and a martyr outside chile is there's a cultural dimension so they're really interested the chilean government and things like that they spend lots of money on music festivals and on publishing poetry and all this kind of thing and of course that explains that explains why people who were at British universities
还有免费的学校午餐。他在几周内就完成了所有这些，我的意思是，这基本上就像一份左翼的愿望清单，他打算把所有事情都做了。这很像斯塔默政府上台后的做法，你觉得呢？土地再分配，汤姆，我还没说完。还有一个因素，我认为这也是阿连德在智利境外成为圣人和烈士的原因之一，那就是文化层面。智利政府对这些非常感兴趣，他们在音乐节和出版诗歌等方面投入了大量资金。当然，这也解释了为什么那些在英国大学里的人
in the 1970s go all misty-eyed because they love all that stuff. Because in the long run, after the coup, lots of intellectuals and artists will end up in European capitals, including London. Of course, exactly. And people like Isabella Ende or the playwright Ariel Dorfman, they become great kind of- Death and the Maiden. Yes, exactly.
在70年代的人会变得热泪盈眶，因为他们热爱这一切。因为从长远来看，政变后，许多知识分子和艺术家最终会流亡到欧洲各国首都，包括伦敦。当然，确实如此。像伊莎贝尔·阿连德或剧作家阿里尔·多夫曼这样的人，他们成为了某种伟大的……《死神与少女》。是的，没错。
They become great proselytizers, I suppose, for the Allende message. So Ariel Dorfman, the playwright, he said, the thing about this is it's not just a, he calls it a remarkable redistribution of income and services to the most underserved members of society, but perhaps more important, he says, this is in the New York Review of Books, that more important than these material advantages was the dignity felt by so many disadvantaged citizens, their sense that they were now the central characters of their nation's history, which is lovely. But all of this comes with a cost, of course, because spending money has to come from somewhere. One of the problems for Allende is that his timing is really terrible. The world economy is obviously about to go into the great slough of the early 1970s.
我想他们成为了阿连德思想的伟大传播者。所以剧作家阿里尔·多夫曼说，这件事的意义不仅在于，他称之为对社会最弱势群体进行了一次非凡的收入和服务再分配，但也许更重要的是，他在《纽约书评》中写道，比这些物质利益更重要的是许多弱势公民感受到的尊严，他们感到自己现在是国家历史的主角，这很美好。但这一切当然是有代价的，因为花钱必须有来源。阿连德面临的问题之一是他的时机非常糟糕。世界经济显然即将进入70年代初的巨大低谷。
Because of the oil crash. Because of the oil crisis and whatnot. The price of copper, the one commodity on which Chile depends more than anything else, is falling at unprecedented levels in the early 70s. So it's down by about a third. I get that. But is there also American string pulling going on behind the scenes to make the impact
因为石油崩盘。因为石油危机之类的原因。铜价，即智利最依赖的商品，在70年代初跌到了前所未有的水平。所以它下跌了大约三分之一。我明白了。但幕后是否有美国在操纵，以加剧这种影响？
worse? There is, Tom. And we'll come to that. We'll come to that in just a second. You see, the American string pulling is really important, but it's not the whole story. If the United States had not existed, been destroyed by a tsunami, our end-age administration would still have run into severe economic problems. Because basically, to pay for all this stuff, his economics minister pumps money into the economy,
确实有，汤姆。我们稍后会谈到这一点。你看，美国的操纵非常重要，但这并不是全部。如果美国不存在，或者被海啸摧毁了，阿连德政府仍然会陷入严重的经济问题。因为基本上，为了支付所有这些开支，他的经济部长向经济中注入了资金，
inflates the currency, and so on. And the result of this is, first of all, you get hyperinflation. At the beginning of 1973, inflation is already 163%. By the end of 1973, it's 500%. So you're getting kind of not quite Weimar Germany levels, but not that far off. Real Chilean GDP has contracted year on year at a rate of about 5% to 6%. I mean, that is colossal, Tom. That's a colossal downturn. And people's wages in real terms are probably worth about half of what they were in 1970 by about 1973 or so.
导致货币通胀等等。结果首先就是恶性通货膨胀。1973年初，通胀率已经达到163%。到1973年底，达到了500%。所以这虽然还没达到魏玛德国的水平，但也相差不远了。智利的实际GDP同比收缩了约5%到6%。我的意思是，这太惊人了，汤姆。这是一个巨大的衰退。到1973年左右，人们的实际工资可能只相当于1970年的一半左右。
So presumably the middle classes don't like that, but all the people who are benefiting from these reforms presumably still remain hugely enthusiastic for INDA's program, despite all this. Right. Well, if you've got your free school milk, you've got a minimum wage, you've got now- Your poetry festivals. There's a poetry festival in the local village. Your kids are being taught to read by volunteers. You're very excited about all this. If you're a lawyer in Santiago, you've been toiling away, working hard for a few years. You've seen the value of your savings wiped out by inflation.
所以大概中产阶级不喜欢这样，但所有从这些改革中受益的人大概仍然对阿连德的计划充满热情，尽管如此。没错。好吧，如果你得到了免费的学校牛奶，有了最低工资，现在还有……你的诗歌节。当地村庄有诗歌节。你的孩子正在由志愿者教识字。你对这一切感到非常兴奋。如果你是圣地亚哥的一名律师，你辛辛苦苦工作了几年。你眼睁睁看着你的积蓄价值被通货膨胀抹去。
You're obviously up in arms, absolutely up in arms. Of course, what the middle classes fear is that Chile will become the next Cuba. Now, even though Allende had signed this pledge, this guarantee that he would not mess with the constitution, he does frighten people because he restores relations with Cuba, which had been cut off in the 1960s. He accepts aid from the USSR. And in 1971, he actually invites Fidel Castro on a state visit. So Castro pitches up, and Castro loves it. He absolutely loves it.
你显然会非常愤怒，绝对会非常愤怒。当然，中产阶级担心的是智利会成为下一个古巴。现在，尽管阿连德签署了这份承诺，保证他不会干涉宪法，但他确实吓坏了人们，因为他恢复了与古巴的关系，而这种关系在60年代就已经中断了。他接受了苏联的援助。1971年，他甚至邀请菲德尔·卡斯特罗进行国事访问。于是卡斯特罗来了，卡斯特罗很喜欢这里。他绝对喜欢这里。
He never goes home. So he's meant to come for seven days, and he ends up staying for 23 days. And he goes around the country. He looks at the free school milk and the land expropriations he looks at the poetry festivals and he says oh this is absolutely brilliant the one thing Castro does say very presciently to Allende is you know you want to be careful here because people will probably move against you and you know Castro of course basically says you know you should tool up well don't worry about this democracy business you know because Castro is a is a man. And Castro actually gives Allende a gun, an AK-47,
他从不回家。他本打算待7天，结果待了23天。他走遍全国。他看着免费的学校牛奶和土地征用，看着诗歌节，他说，哦，这太棒了。卡斯特罗确实非常敏锐地对阿连德说，你知道，你在这里要小心，因为人们可能会反对你，而且你知道，卡斯特罗当然基本上说，你知道你应该武装起来，别管这些民主的事情，因为卡斯特罗是个硬汉。卡斯特罗甚至给了阿连德一把枪，一把AK-47，
I think it is, which will come back. Feature later. Yeah, feature later. Castro, you could argue, is not entirely wrong because two days after Allende had been inaugurated on the 6th of November, 1970. We know from the declassified documents that Nixon convened in Washington, his entire National Security Council, to discuss ways, and I quote, to bring about his downfall. And actually, the quotes here are pretty extraordinary. So this is Nixon. Our main concern in Chile is the prospect that he can consolidate himself and the picture projected to the world will be his success. No impression should be permitted in Latin America that they can get away with this, that it is safe to go this way.
我想是这样，这以后还会出现。是的，稍后会出现。你可以说卡斯特罗并不完全错误，因为在阿连德于1970年11月6日就职两天后。我们从解密文件中得知，尼克松在华盛顿召集了他的整个国家安全委员会，讨论如何，我引用一下，“促成他的垮台”。实际上，这里的引语非常惊人。这是尼克松的话：我们在智利的主要担忧是他可能巩固自己的地位，向世界展示的形象将是他的成功。在拉丁美洲，绝不能让任何人觉得他们可以侥幸逃脱，觉得走这条路是安全的。
All over the world, it's too much of the fashion to kick us around. His Secretary of State, Bill Rogers, who's actually a bit of a figurehead, Bill Rogers says, yes, we want to do this right and bring him down. The Secretary of Defense, Melvin Laird, we have to do everything we can to hurt Allende and bring him down. And the way they, I mean, it's a sort of multifaceted approach. The main thing they do is economic pressure, which you mentioned already, Tom. So that note that Richard Helms, the CIA director, had put, that handwritten note, make the economy scream. That is what they do. They shut down all financing, all American financing, all American loans to Chile. They lobby private investors to do the same.
在世界各地，欺负我们已经成了一种风气。他的国务卿比尔·罗杰斯，实际上只是个傀儡，比尔·罗杰斯说，是的，我们想把这件事做好，让他下台。国防部长梅尔文·莱尔德说，我们必须尽一切努力伤害阿连德并让他下台。他们采取的方式，我的意思是，这是一种多管齐下的方法。他们所做的主要事情是经济压力，你已经提到了，汤姆。所以中情局局长理查德·赫尔姆斯写的那张手写便条，让经济尖叫起来。这就是他们所做的。他们切断了所有融资，所有美国对智利的贷款。他们游说私人投资者也这样做。
They put massive pressure on U.S. banks and indeed international banks like the World Bank or the Inter-American Development Bank to cut off all their loans to Chile. Even such small things, but important things like this. Lots of Chilean trucks, cars, factories, machines, and so on are dependent on US parts, parts imported from the US. The Nixon administration works very hard behind the scenes to shut all supplies of these things down, to cut off the flow, basically. So things are bad anyway because of the global economic situation, but this really isn't helping.
他们对美国银行，甚至像世界银行或美洲开发银行这样的国际银行施加巨大压力，要求切断对智利的所有贷款。甚至是一些小事，但很重要，比如这个。许多智利的卡车、汽车、工厂、机器等都依赖美国零件，即从美国进口的零件。尼克松政府在幕后非常努力地切断所有这些东西的供应，基本上是切断了流动。所以由于全球经济形势，情况本来就很糟糕，但这真的没有帮助。
Exactly right. Exactly. Meanwhile, millions of dollars being pumped in on an unprecedented scale to opposition newspapers, to opposition groups, right-wingwing groups i'll just give you three examples one they spend about four million dollars i would say in total uh in gifts to the newspaper el mercurio the newspaper that is part owned by itt and what is el mercurio like dominic so what kind of newspaper is that it's probably like the daily express or the Daily Telegraph, Tom, I would say. Right. So it's a staunchly right-wing best-selling newspaper. Yes, it is. It's inflammatory.
完全正确。确实。与此同时，数百万美元以前所未有的规模注入到反对派报纸和反对派团体中，右翼团体。我给你举三个例子：第一，他们总共花费了大约四百万美元，以赠款的形式给《信使报》，这份报纸部分由ITT拥有。多米尼克，《信使报》是什么样的？那是什么样的报纸？汤姆，我想它可能就像《每日快报》或《每日电讯报》。没错。所以它是一份坚定的右翼畅销报纸。是的，它是。它具有煽动性。
Elmer Cure is crucial in creating the coup atmosphere, the pre-coup atmosphere, and saying, we have to have a coup, someone has to step in, he's a Marxist. Oh, God, so they're openly saying this? Oh, yeah, absolutely. They're sort of saying... Okay, so that's quite punchy. Yeah. Isn't that against the law to incite a coup i imagine it would be i don't know about chilean law but i've
《信使报》在制造政变氛围、政变前氛围方面至关重要，它说，我们必须发动政变，必须有人介入，他是马克思主义者。天哪，所以他们公开这么说？哦，是的，绝对。他们基本上是在说……好吧，这很有冲击力。是的。煽动政变不是违法的吗？我想应该是的，我不了解智利法律，但我
probably incited a coup in some of my some of my pieces over the years tom i mean i don't think overtly have you uh sandbrook admits don't cite in coups so there's yay to el marquero secondly they pump in a lot of money to business groups that are opposed to Allende. So particularly the truckers, the truck owners, because they have the power to paralyze the economy if you cut down all transport. So there's that because the Allende government is beset by trucker strikes. And the third thing is they pump money into the Christian Democrat Party, so the biggest opposition party. But crucially, the Christian Democrats had previously been a sort of semi-reformist party. Now they're being pushed further and further to the right under CIA influence. They basically want to transform the Christian Democrat Party to prepare the ground for some sort of action against Allende. And when you say further to the right, do you mean economically or do you mean further right as in, let's get out the dark glasses and lock people up and start applying electrodes to poets kind of thing? Yes, because the economic right, so lots of people will associate that with a group called
可能在过去几年的某些文章中煽动过政变，汤姆。我的意思是，我不认为我公开做过。你有吗？桑德布鲁克承认没有煽动政变。所以，这就是给《信使报》的钱。其次，他们向反对阿连德的商业团体注入了大量资金。特别是卡车司机，卡车车主，因为如果你切断所有运输，他们有能力瘫痪经济。所以有这个原因，因为阿连德政府受到卡车司机罢工的困扰。第三件事是他们向基督教民主党注入资金，这是最大的反对党。但关键是，基督教民主党以前是一个半改良主义的政党。现在，在中情局的影响下，他们被推得越来越靠右。他们基本上想改造基督教民主党，为针对阿连德的某种行动铺平道路。当你提到“更靠右”时，你是说经济上，还是说更右，比如戴上墨镜、把人关起来、开始对诗人使用电击那种？是的，因为经济右翼，很多人会把这与一个叫
the Chicago Boys, economists who came in to subject the Chilean economy to this extraordinary economic experiment in the 1970s. There's not much talk of that at this point. It's actually the sort of electrodes and dark glasses, right? Yeah. Okay. I'm amazed that Allende is letting... I mean, it's absolutely a tribute to what you were saying that he's not... I mean, he's absolutely not Castro, that he's allowing newspapers to kind of promote this. But Tom, what can he do? Change the law, I would have thought, to say that you can't foster coups in the press, I would have thought.
“芝加哥男孩”的群体联系起来，这些经济学家在70年代进入智利，对智利经济进行了这种非凡的经济实验。此时还没有太多关于那方面的讨论。实际上是那种电击和墨镜的右翼？是的。好吧。我很惊讶阿连德竟然允许……我的意思是，这绝对证明了你所说的，他绝对不是卡斯特罗，他允许报纸以这种方式进行宣传。但汤姆，他能做什么？我想他应该修改法律，规定不能在媒体中煽动政变。
He doesn't have an absolute majority in Congress and the Chilean Supreme Court is dominated by much more conservative figures. So Chile has a system of the separation of powers. So this suggests that actually the democracy is working pretty well. Well, because of the nature of Allende's experiments and the nature of the passions involved,
他在国会没有绝对多数席位，智利最高法院由更保守的人物主导。所以智利有一个权力分立的制度。这表明实际上民主运作得相当不错。嗯，因为阿连德实验的性质以及所涉及的激情的性质，
the early 1970s is putting more strain on that system than it's ever been under before. So by 1973, as we will find out next time, there is enormous tension between the Supreme Court and the Congress on one hand and Allende himself on the other. So the more conservatives and those people who basically are saying, he's going much too far. You shouldn't be doing this in a democracy because they basically say, his experiment is turning everything to rack and ruin and the economy is falling apart and all of this kind of thing. But you're right, Allende, he does not appear at all to be a violent man, a man who is keen to employ violence or repressive or anything like that because he would have tried it He would have done so, and he doesn't do so. And actually, maybe one reason he doesn't do so is he knows that he still has a lot of support in the country. And in the spring of 1973, there was going to be a congressional election. So this is on March the 4th. And the CIA,
70年代初给该制度带来的压力比以往任何时候都要大。所以到1973年，正如我们下次会发现的那样，最高法院和国会一方面与阿连德本人另一方面之间存在巨大的紧张关系。所以那些更保守的人，以及那些基本上说“他走得太远了”的人。你不应该在民主制度下这样做，因为他们基本上说，他的实验正在把一切搞得一团糟，经济正在崩溃，诸如此类。但你是对的，阿连德，他看起来一点也不像是一个暴力的人，一个热衷于使用暴力或镇压之类手段的人，因为如果他想尝试，他早就做了，但他没有这样做。实际上，他没有这样做的原因之一可能是他知道他在国内仍然有很多支持。在1973年春天，将举行国会选举。所以这是在3月4日。而中情局，
Nixon and Kissinger, the State Department, El Mercurio, the truckers, the middle classes, all of these people have pinned their hopes. Allende will get a massive bloody nose in the congressional elections. That will allow us, it will give us a two-thirds majority in Congress, so he could be impeached if necessary, and all this stuff can be blocked. And we can put Chile back on what they regard as the road to sanity. And actually what happens is, although the opposition parties between them get the majority of the votes, Allende's candidates actually pick up two seats
尼克松和基辛格、国务院、《信使报》、卡车司机、中产阶级，所有这些人都在寄予厚望。阿连德将在国会选举中遭受惨败。这将允许我们，它将给我们国会三分之二的多数席位，这样如果必要的话他可以被弹劾，所有这些事情都可以被阻止。我们可以让智利回到他们认为的理智之路。但实际上发生的是，尽管反对党加起来获得了多数选票，但阿连德的候选人实际上赢得了两个席位
in the Senate, two extra seats, and they get six extra seats in the Congress. So he's better off than he was before he started. I mean, this to the Americans, to the CIA people who are based in Chile, to the embassy and whatnot, is unbelievably infuriating. As far as they're concerned, this now means a sort of parliamentary option using straight parliamentary politics to beat Allende is off the table. It hasn't worked. It hasn't worked at all. And that, in their minds, leaves them with only one option. And that option is now to work towards a full-scale military coup. Okay, so that sets us up for tomorrow's episode where we will look at the coup. But Dominic, I think what impresses me about this story, and I really know very, very little about it, as I'm sure listeners will have been able to gauge, is just how deeply rooted
在参议院，两个额外的席位，他们在国会获得了六个额外的席位。所以他比开始时处境更好。我的意思是，这对美国人，对驻智利的中情局人员，对大使馆等等来说，简直令人愤怒。在他们看来，这意味着通过纯粹的议会政治来击败阿连德的议会选择已经行不通了。它根本没用。在他们看来，这只剩下一个选择。那个选择就是现在致力于一场全面的军事政变。好吧，这为我们明天的节目做了铺垫，我们将审视那场政变。但多米尼克，我认为这个故事让我印象深刻的是，我确实知之甚少，我相信听众也能看出来，那就是智利民主的结构在70年代初似乎是多么根深蒂固
and secure the structures of Chilean democracy seem to have been in the early 70s. I mean, all this strain, but they seem to be holding. Yes. Well, Chile hasn't had a coup for the best part of half a century. It becomes important sometimes to countries' sense of identity, who they are, that they are a democratic country. If you'd asked a Chilean in the beginning of 1973, they would say, we are not Brazil. We're not Argentina. We are South America's outlier.
且稳固。我的意思是，尽管有所有这些压力，但它们似乎还在坚持。是的。好吧，智利在过去半个世纪里没有发生过政变。有时这对国家的身份认同感很重要，即他们是谁，他们是一个民主国家。如果你在1973年初问一个智利人，他们会说，我们不是巴西。我们不是阿根廷。我们是南美的异类。
We are a democratic, civilized, sophisticated people. The country of Pablo Neruda and fine wines and all this sort of stuff. And we don't go in for the dark glasses and the cattle prods. Right. And of course, things would turn out rather differently. Okay. Well, that terrible story coming up tomorrow when we will look at the coup that topples Allende and brings General Pinochet, Pinochet, Pinochet, however you pronounce him.
我们是一个民主、文明、成熟的民族。巴勃罗·聂鲁达和美酒之乡等等。我们不搞墨镜和电击棒那一套。没错。当然，事情的结果会大不相同。好吧，那个可怕的故事将在明天播出，届时我们将审视推翻阿连德并带来皮诺切特将军的政变，皮诺切特，皮诺切特，无论你怎么发音。
We will discuss that tomorrow on tomorrow's episode. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free
我们将在明天的节目中讨论这个问题。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告
listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。